The real people went away I'll find a better way Someday Leaving only me And my dreams All right, this is Joel Blackstock with the Taproot Therapy Podcast coming to you with Julian Walker of the Conspiratuality Podcast. And I'm in Birmingham, Alabama, not in Birmingham, England. No, so no Peaky Blinders impressions today.
真实的人们离开了，我会找到更好的方式，总有一天，只留下我和我的梦想。好的，我是Joel Blackstock，这是Taproot Therapy播客，今天和我在一起的是Conspiratuality播客的Julian Walker。我人在阿拉巴马州的伯明翰，不是英国的伯明翰。所以，今天没有《浴血黑帮》的模仿秀。
Did you almost say Peaky Bastards? You'd think that'd be a line in that show somewhere. I don't know. Is it Brum? I think it's the nickname for Birmingham because occasionally... Brummy. Yeah, it's a Brummy accent. And the funny thing about it is I'm from South Africa.
你刚才是不是差点说成“Peaky Bastards”？你可能会觉得那部剧里会有这句台词。我不知道。那是Brum吗？我想那是伯明翰的昵称，因为偶尔……Brummy。是的，那是Brummy口音。有趣的是，我来自南非。
It actually has some overlaps with... There's a little bit of a South African similarity. Is that because of how English is taught to foreign language speakers or because enough English people go and I'm always interested in that stuff, but I don't know a ton about it. Yeah, no, it's more just the sort of random ways that different dialects and accents develop in different parts of the world. And sometimes you you just have similar like there's actually some similar vowel sounds in Brummie which is Birmingham England in South Africa and in New Orleans and it's you know it's kind of sort of like the flat some of the flatter vowel sounds wow yeah I guess that makes sense like a convergent um evolution of language like it goes back to a similar place that it's already departed from yeah can you hear
它实际上和……南非口音有一点相似之处。这是因为英语是如何教给外语使用者的，还是因为有很多英国人去那里？我一直对这些东西很感兴趣，但我了解得不多。是的，不，这更多是不同方言和口音在世界不同地区发展的随机方式。有时你只是有相似之处，比如在南非、新奥尔良和英国伯明翰的Brummie口音中，确实有一些相似的元音。你知道，这有点像是一些更平的元音。哇，是的，我想这说得通，就像语言的趋同进化，它回到了它已经偏离的相似起点。是的，你能听到
me okay this mic is new um yeah it sounds great okay perfect well i um yeah we we've had like a phenomenon where it happened it was happening a lot i don't know if airlines got better at catching it but it was people who were on vacation either in the caribbean or like in california from england would try and fly home and buy a ticket to birmingham alabama and then be like what and then like after uh and the city put up like the first two couples as like a tourism thing and was like oh funny you know like yeah go do this stuff yeah and then it happened like five more times and they're like oh we're not doing this every time you guys don't read the rest of the stuff yeah well for people not familiar with your podcast or your book, and you've got other
我说话吗？这个麦克风是新的。嗯，是的，听起来很棒。好的，完美。嗯，我们经历过一种现象，这种情况发生了很多次。我不知道航空公司是否更擅长捕捉它，但确实有在加勒比海或加利福尼亚度假的英国人，试图飞回家时买了一张去阿拉巴马州伯明翰的机票，然后就一脸困惑。后来，城市把前几对游客当作旅游宣传，觉得这很有趣。但后来又发生了五六次，他们就说，哦，我们不能每次都这样，你们这些人不看清楚剩下的信息。是的，对于那些不熟悉你的播客或你的书的人，你还有其他
projects too, before we like get into the topic, could you just give us kind of a brief overview of that? I mean, I'd like to introduce, I don't want to introduce it wrong, but I've listened to it for a long time and y'all also wear a lot of hats. So it's not, it's not an easy thing to, and you have different perspectives, know different yeah people yeah so i am part of a trio who produces something called the conspirituality podcast conspirituality is sort of a portmanteau a combination of two different words conspiracy and spirituality it's not a term that we coined it was coined by academics uh back in 2011 and has been used by different people in different ways.
项目，在我们进入主题之前，你能给我们做一个简要的概述吗？我的意思是，我不想介绍错了，但我听了很久，你们也身兼数职。所以这不是一件容易的事，而且你们有不同的视角，认识不同的人。是的，我是制作Conspiratuality播客的三人组之一。Conspiratuality是一个合成词，结合了“阴谋”（conspiracy）和“灵性”（spirituality）两个词。这不是我们创造的术语，它是由学者在2011年创造的，并被不同的人以不同的方式使用。
But we came together at the start of the pandemic, all three of us, my colleagues are Derek Barris and Matthew Remsky, all three of us knew each other online and had been involved in different website and book and blogging sort of projects over the course of about 10 years, where we each were yoga teachers. We each had been involved in the sort of yoga and wellness marketplace and career and communities for a long time, for like probably each of us for about 30 years, 20 to 30 years. But we had a critical eye towards a lot of the aspects of it that were more pseudo-scientific that were uh could be characterized as spiritual bypass that could be characterized as depoliticized and sort of wanting to transcend the mere world of like real human concerns well you get projection like anytime anyone's sitting around with a bunch of intuitive feelers really cultivating an inner world i think there's this inevitability that some people are like, yeah, we're talking about the inner world when
我们在疫情开始时聚在一起，我们三个人，我的同事是Derek Barris和Matthew Remsky。我们三个人在网上认识，在过去大约10年里参与了不同的网站、书籍和博客项目，我们每个人都曾是瑜伽老师。我们每个人都长期参与瑜伽和健康市场、职业和社区，可能每个人都有大约30年，20到30年的经验。但我们对其中许多更伪科学的方面持批判态度，这些方面可以被定性为“灵性逃避”（spiritual bypass），可以被定性为去政治化，以及想要超越纯粹的真实人类关怀的世界。嗯，你会得到投射，就像任何时候有人和一群直觉敏锐的人坐在一起，真正培养内心世界时，我认为不可避免地有些人会说，是的，当我们使用这种语言时，我们在谈论内心世界。人们开始说，不，我是魔法。这就是一切。这就是在瑜伽和灵性社区中事情达到顶峰的地方。但我认为在2020年期间，由于很多原因，这种情况发生了很多。是的。所以我们观察到的，这完全正确。我很乐意和你进一步讨论这个问题。我们在2020年初，当疫情刚刚成为现实时，观察到的是，在我们的社交动态中，我们开始看到所有这些阴谋论材料。在某种程度上，我们并不感到惊讶，但其规模和普遍性令人震惊。对我来说，有些人曾经是我喜欢的人，比如Charles Michael Eisenstein
we're using this language. People start to go, no, I'm magic. This is everything. And that's where you get certain places where things come to a head in yoga and spiritual communities. But I think that happened a lot during 2020 for a lot of reasons. Yeah. So what we observed, and that's exactly right. And I'd love to talk further with you about that. What we observed in early, in 2020, as the pandemic was just sort of becoming a reality, was that on our social feeds, we started seeing all of this conspiratorial material. And to some extent, we were not surprised, but the scale of it and the ubiquity of it was kind of stunning well for me it was that some of the people used to be people who i kind of liked like um charles michael eisenstein
或者叫Michael，是Charles Eisenstein吗？他有一些我喜欢的东西，当我在大学时，那是一个对经济持批判态度的人，他有一些有趣的思维实验，他属于我猜你会称之为“石油峰值”邻近泡沫的人。石油峰值作为一种阴谋论正在瓦解，但那些人仍然说，系统因为其他原因不可持续，即使我们能在石油耗尽前结束地球上的生命，我们可能也不应该这样做。我以为其中一些人是清醒且连贯的，然后它就开始走向别处了。是的，我的意思是，Charles Eisenstein是一个有趣的人物。
or is it michael is it charles eisenstein he had like uh some stuff that i liked and when i was in college that was a guy critical of economy and looking at like he had some interesting thought experiments and he was part of i guess what you'd call like the peak oil adjacent bubble like peak oil was kind of falling apart as a conspiracy theory but those guys still were like but the system's not sustainable for other reasons even if we could end life on earth before we run out of oil we probably should just not do that and i thought some of those guys were lucid and coherent, and then it just started to go somewhere else. Yeah, I mean, Charles Eisenstein is sort of an interesting character.
我们研究了许多我们称之为“阴谋灵性主义者”（conspiritualists）的人物，他们往往在网上非常有影响力。他们往往有一种灵性或新时代的倾向，但他们已经变得……而且它可以向任何方向发展，对吧？他们最初的倾向可能是新时代的，逐渐变得更加阴谋论，最终变得更加右翼，这是典型的趋势。不是统一的，但非常普遍。或者反过来，他们开始时更多处于某种右翼或阴谋论模式，但也类似于“兄弟科学”（bro science），就像所有聚集在Joe Rogan、Tim Ferriss和Dave Asprey周围的人，然后开始通过阴谋论的视角编织某种关于正在发生的事情的形而上学信仰。所以我们只是开始注意到所有这些事情的发生。因为我们认识很久了，我们说，嘿，让我们做几期播客，把这些拆解开来，因为我们发现很多朋友、同事、学生和周围的人都在说，嘿，你注意到了吗？到底发生了什么？所以我们开始互相讨论，它就火了。它变成了这个播客，这是一种在正确的时间出现在正确地点的感觉。我们很快就开始有很多听众，分享我们的内容，写信给我们说，嘿，你能报道这个吗？你能看看那个吗？你听说过这个人吗？它对我们来说变成了一种社区现象。
We've looked at many, many figures that we refer to as conspiritualists who tend to be sort of very influential online. They tend to have a kind of spiritual or New age orientation, but they have become, and it could go in either direction, right? They could be new age in their initial orientation, they become gradually more conspiratorial, and eventually more right-wing has been the typical trend. Not uniformly, but it's very common. Or it's the other way around, where they start off more in some kind of either right-wing or conspiracy theorist mode, but also sort of like bro science, like all the people who are clustered around Joe Rogan and Tim Ferriss and Dave Asprey and those sorts of folks who then start weaving some sort of spiritual set of
这已经是四年了。2022年，我们通过Random House和Hachette获得了图书合同。我们去年六月出版了一本书，叫《阴谋灵性：新时代阴谋如何成为健康威胁》。是的，我们上过《纽约时报》和《滚石》杂志，上过NPR，上过BBC，我接受过新西兰电台的采访，你知道，我们上过CNN。
metaphysical beliefs about what's going on through a conspiratorial lens. So we just started noticing all of this happening. And because we've known each other for a long time, we said, hey, let's do a couple of podcast episodes where we just break this down, because we're finding a lot of friends and colleagues and students and people around us are just saying, hey, have you noticed this? What the hell's going on? So we started talking about it with each other and it just took off. And it turned into this podcast that it was sort of right place, right time. We very quickly started to get a lot of people listening to us and sharing our stuff and writing to us and saying, hey, could you cover this? And could you look at that? And have you heard of this person? And it became this sort of community phenomenon for us.
它确实变成了我们早期谈论的事情，许多不同的新闻媒体开始关注并说，哦，这是一个有趣的故事。你通常会将瑜伽、健康、新时代世界与嬉皮士、多元文化、对东方灵性的兴趣、温和联系在一起。而这个世界可能成为例如对“匿名者Q”（QAnon）感兴趣的温床，这对很多人来说是令人震惊的，并且持续如此。大约每六个月左右，我们就会遇到一些新的记者说，等等，什么？我想这一点现在已经减弱了，但那确实是整整三年的情况。是的，那是一个有趣的时期，我的意思是，我们
And that's been four years now. And in 2022, we got a book deal through Random House and Hachette. We published a book last June called Conspiratuality, how new age conspiracies became a health threat. And yeah, we've gotten, we've been in the New Yorkork times and rolling stone we've been on npr we've been on bbc i was interviewed for new zealand radio you know we've been on cnn it
现在仍然处于有趣的时代，但所有不同的文化泡沫都同时浮出水面。所以，你知道，我记得很久以前，当我在询问瑜伽或其他什么时，有一个人，他是塔斯卡卢萨的一名瑜伽教练。他说，看，有很多书，它们很棒，但当它们讲到瑜伽不仅仅是伸展，你必须与某种行星光环对齐时，就停止阅读吧，因为那是……如果你想读，你可以读，但不要注意那个。我觉得这很有趣，而有些人，你知道，确实……我不
really became the thing that we were talking about early that a lot of different news outlets started cottoning onto and going oh this this is an interesting story like you normally associate the yoga wellness new age world with being hippie, with being multicultural, with being interested in Eastern spirituality, with being kind of mellow. And the idea that this world could be sort of a breeding ground for say, interest in QAnon was kind of mind blowing for a lot of people and continues to be like every six months or so we'll encounter some new reporter who's saying wait what and i think that's kind of waned at this point but that was the case for a good three years yeah it was a it was an interesting time i mean we
确定所有的种类，但其中一种更多与灵性转化和不同的事情有关。但确实有很多人在瑜伽或其他活动中感到自己有了灵性觉醒。我的意思是，你来自那个世界，你是如何概念化它的？或者在你不得不思考它之前，你有没有想过它？你知道，有些人我们不思考我们的神话。通常这就是它的本质。我认为对我来说，当播客开始时，我已经教了20多年瑜伽。我在这个社区里待了大概快30年了。我从十几岁起就是一个灵性追求者。我在十几岁后期和成年早期尝试过迷幻药。
still are in interesting times but everything lots of different uh cultural bubbles kind of came to the surface at once there um and so, you know, I remember a long time ago, a guy was, when I was asking about yoga or something, he was like a yoga instructor in Tuscaloosa. And he was like, look, there's all these books and they're great, but just stop reading them when they get to the part where they're telling you that yoga is not just stretching, that you have to align with some kind of planetary aura, because that is where you can read it if you want, but just don't pay attention to that and i thought that was kind of interesting uh whereas some people you know do um i'm not
我做过大量的治疗。我做过大量的，你知道，那种非传统的治疗，包括迷幻治疗、呼吸法和强烈的身体工作。我拥有的那位瑜伽老师非常专注于瑜伽如何处理身体中的创伤，不管好坏。关于这一点有一些好的方面。也有一些有点可疑的方面。但是的，我一直在思考这些事情。我一直对我在瑜伽世界中看到的很多东西持批判态度，认为它们太超自然了，太确信大师是神圣的，或者拥有超自然能力，或者对现实本质有完美的洞察力。现实，那只是那种微妙的暗示，我不是肯定地告诉你，但如果你继续练习这种伸展，我会暗示它最终会让你拥有魔法力量。是的，我会暗示我有，而不完全说出来。嗯哼，是的，是的，所以它是
sure on all the kinds but one of them is like more has to do with spiritual transformation and different different things but there's a lot of people that do feel like they have a spiritual awakening during yoga or something i mean you you kind of come from that world how did you conceptualize it or did you think about it until you had to, you know, some people we don't think about our mythology. Typically that's kind of what it is. I think that for me, having, when the podcast started, I'd been teaching yoga for, you know, 20, 20 plus years. I've been in and around the community for probably close to 30 years. I'd been a spiritual seeker since I was a teenager. I'd experimented with psychedelics as an older teenager and a young adult.
一个极其沉重的话题。看，我们必须承认西方与东方灵性的互动，尤其是瑜伽，是这种互动或话题中最突出的版本。看，我们必须承认西方与东方灵性的互动，尤其是瑜伽，是这种互动或迭代中最突出的版本。有很多，有东方主义，有殖民主义，有一种感觉，你知道，白人欧洲人来到印度次大陆，压迫和统治那些他们认为不如他们的人，并想“教化”他们，但同时也对他们的灵性实践着迷，对吧？随着时间的推移，出现了那种现象，你有一些英国贵族
I had done tons of therapy. I had done tons of, you know, sort of experiential, less run-of-the-mill therapy, including psychedelic therapy and breath work and intense body work. And the yoga teacher that I had was very focused on how yoga could be about working with trauma in the body, sort of for better or for worse. There were some good things about that. There were some things about that that were a little bit dodgy. But yeah, I'd always been thinking about these things. And I'd always had a critical eyebrow raised towards a lot of what I saw in the yoga world as being a little too supernatural, a little too convinced of claims of gurus being divine or having paranormal abilities or having perfect insight into the nature of reality. reality that's just that subtle little implication that i'm not telling you for sure but if you keep working on this stretching i'm gonna imply that it will make you have magic powers eventually yeah i'm gonna imply that i have without quite saying that uh-huh yeah yeah so it's it's it's
他们本质上是在说，哦，我发现了，你知道，古老印度传统的秘密深奥真理，我现在要写书并发表关于它的演讲。但后来你也确实有，我认为你有一个向另一个方向发展的动态，有受过良好教育、富有魅力和口才的印度瑜伽哲学支持者，特别是像Vivekananda在20世纪初在世界宗教议会上发言，然后是开始涌向美国的古鲁浪潮，因为他们意识到，哦，有一个对这个感兴趣的庞大市场，从70年代开始，一直加速到90年代。而且，你知道，再次强调，不管好坏，其中一些是高尚传统的真诚和值得信赖的老师。其中一些
an incredibly loaded topic look we like we have to acknowledge the the western interaction with eastern spirituality and especially yoga is sort of the most prominent uh version of this or or topic. Look, we have to acknowledge the Western interaction with Eastern spirituality, and especially yoga is sort of the most prominent version of this or iteration of this. There's a lot, there's Orientalism, there's colonialism, there's the sense of, you know, white Europeans coming to the Indian subcontinent and oppressing and dominating people who they saw as, you know, lesser than them, and kind of wanted to civilize them, but then also sort of becoming fascinated with their spiritual practices, right? And over time, there, so there was that phenomenon where you had these English noblemen
信仰我们在今天的谈话中可能会有异议，而其中一些人，你知道，确实是机会主义的江湖骗子。然而，这些信仰中有多少是被那种文化暗示为隐喻或寓言，当它从原生语境中被移除并带到西方时，变得字面化和具体化了？我不知道我是否有这个问题的答案。你知道，我认为这是一个非常非常有趣的问题。我会告诉你，作为一个对这一切从非常理性和心理学角度感到好奇的灵性追求者，作为一个年轻人，真的对荣格很感兴趣，真的非常热爱约瑟夫·坎贝尔……
who essentially were saying, oh, I have discovered, you know, the secret esoteric truths of the ancient Indian traditions, and I'm now going to write books about it and give speeches about it but then you did also have i think that you had a dynamic going the other direction where there were uh very educated and charismatic and eloquent uh indian proponents of yogic philosophy especially like vivekananda speaking at the world uh parliament of churches i think it's called back in the in the early 20th century and and then the the the wave of gurus that started heading uh to the u.s because they realized oh there's a there's a big market of people who are interested in this starting in the 70s and only accelerating as you get all the way through into the 90s and you know for again for better or for worse, some of these were very sincere and trustworthy teachers of a noble tradition. Some of the
真的感兴趣。你是那一代崇拜Terence McKenna的人吗？看起来很多比我更……只是比我更Gen X一点的人。是的，我们确实……是的，比我更Gen X。是的，绝对。绝对。但我同时也深受那整波婴儿潮一代的影响，他们在他们那一代中真的很独特，愿意去印度，去缅甸，去尼泊尔，去追求他们的迷恋。当然，他们通常是非常有特权的西方人，能够进行那种灵性旅游，然后回来并说，哦，我花了，你知道，像Jack Kornfield，我花了，是什么，六年，八年
beliefs of which we may take issue with in today's conversation, and some of them were, you know, really opportunistic charlatans. How many of those beliefs, though, were implied by that culture to be a metaphor or an allegory that became literalized and sort of concrete when it was removed from its native context and brought to the west and i don't know i have an answer to that question you know i think it's a very very interesting question and i would tell you that as a as a spiritual seeker who was very curious about all of this from a from a quite intellectual and psychological point of view as a young man uh really interested in jung really really passionate about joseph campbell um
在佛教寺院里。这是我学到的。这是我要教给你们的。有一整群人，所以Ram Dass是其中的一部分，真的是早期的人之一。你有像Jack Kornfield、John Wellwood、John Salzberg、Joseph Goldstein这样的人。他们有一整群人，Alan Watts实际上是一个大人物，对吧？也许他甚至稍微老一点。但本质上他们所做的是去像印度这样的国家，学习这些传统，学习禅宗，学习瑜伽，去进行长时间的内观（Vipassana），寻找他们认为真正富有同情心和真正智慧的老师。然后他们以一种更世俗、更理性、通常更偏向心理学的方式为西方受众进行翻译。所以我绝对有立场回到你的问题。我长期以来一直支持这样一种观点，即本质上所有这些深奥、长期、复杂的神秘哲学和实践，确实在隐喻和关于现实的字面陈述之间有区别，他们确实以一种符合我西方理性观点的方式弄清楚了这一点。随着时间的推移，我开始看到这可能只是东方主义的下一波浪潮，在那里有一种理想化，哦，这比西方的字面主义好得多，或者它是“永恒哲学”。完全正确。所以你是说，我认为这就是为什么有些人会从极右转向极左的原因之一，因为无意识的直觉实际上只是逃避，而且看起来是一样的。
really interested were you in the generation that looked up to terence mckenna a lot it seems like a lot of people that were more gen uh just a little bit more gen xy than yes we're really yeah more Genesi than I was. Yeah, absolutely. Absolutely. But I also was very influenced by that whole wave of boomers who, who were really unique in their, in their generation who were willing to go to India, to go to Burma, to go to Nepal, to, to pursue their fascination. And of course, very often they were quite privileged Wetzners who were able to do that kind of spiritual tourism and then come back and say, oh, I've spent, you know, like Jack Kornfield, I've spent, what is it, six years, eight years
所以如果我说，我不需要改变我的家庭结构。我不需要学习任何东西。我不需要站起来更好地沟通。我只需要把它交给耶稣，对吧？那有什么区别？而且，哦，不，不，那是错的。我现在要转向东方。这块紫水晶会治好我的腺病，但我不需要做任何事或改变任何事。你知道，同样是将你自己的控制点放弃给这个其他东西。所以你确实看到人们，你知道，这种选择在某种程度上是审美的，我认为我们忘记了这一点。
in a Buddhist monastery. And here's what I've learned. And here's what I'm going to teach you about. There was a whole, so Ram Dass is part of that, really one of the early ones. You have people like Jack Kornfield, John Wellwood, John Salzberg, Joseph Goldstein. There's a whole group of them who were, Alan Watts actually is a huge one, right? And maybe he's even a little bit older. But essentially what they were doing is going to countries like India, studying these traditions, studying Zen Buddhism, studying yoga, going and doing Vipassana for extended periods of time, finding teachers who they found to be really compassionate and really wise. And then they were translating it in a kind of more secular, more intellectual, often more psychologically oriented way for a
他们到底在说什么？重点是什么？是的。是的。所以你提到了一个我们也许可以稍微深入探讨的话题，那就是这种方法和社区是否具有过程导向。你如何……你如何在宗教中拥有某种东西，或者，你知道，我认为其他关于成长和改变的社区，你需要这些规则，但后来你放手了。这不是等级制度，因为它不是邪教。这是一种放弃并拥有更深理解的过程。
Western audience. So I definitely had the position to go back to your question. I espoused the point of view for a very, very long time that essentially all of these deep, longstanding, sophisticated mystical philosophies and practices really had the distinction between metaphor and literal statements about reality, that they really had that figured out in a way that accorded with my Western intellectual sort of point of view and over time i've come to see that that may have been sort of the next wave of orientalism where where there was this this idealizing of a kind of oh this is so much better than uh western literalist uh or it's a perennial philosophy. Exactly. So you're saying, and I think that's one of the reasons why you have people who make a hard switch from the hard right to a hard left is because unconscious intuition really is just avoidance and it looks the same.
你如何区分一个真正做到这一点的人和一个只是在做姿态的人？你知道，因为语言是一样的。是的。是的。而且，你知道，我知道你也谈论了很多关于邪教的问题。我们也一样。所以对我来说，关于美国与东方灵性交集的一个非常能说明问题的事情是，早期，最受欢迎和最受认可的印度宗教团体之一，变得流行并获得了很多西方追随者，是哈瑞奎师那运动（Hare Krishna movement），对吧？奎师那意识运动。你想要一朵花吗？再说一遍？
So if I'm saying, I don't need to change my family structure. I don't need to learn anything. I don't need to stand up and communicate better. I just need to turn it over to Jesus, right? What's the difference in that? And, oh, no, no, that's wrong. I'm going to go Eastern now. This amethyst will cure my scrofula, but I don't need to do anything or change anything. You know, there's the same giving up of your own locus of control to this other thing. And so you do see people, you know, the choice is kind of aesthetic in a way that I think we forget.
你想要一朵花吗？你在机场想要一朵花吗？是的。所以当你看到那个时，我认为最初，这也有点符合我们的项目。最初，当你看到那个时，你可能会说，好吧，看看这些嬉皮士。看看这些嬉皮士。他们退出了社会。他们经历了一次迷幻之旅，他们决定，你知道，隐藏的灵性才是真理。他们留着这种滑稽的发型，额头上有条纹，穿着这些衣服，在机场像快乐的拍手者一样跳舞，试图转化我们。但实际上，那个特定的教派极其专制，它与原教旨主义基督教的共同点远多于它与我认为像你我这样的人在某个时候可能被吸引的那种东方神秘主义的共同点。而且民族主义，只是另一种民族主义。绝对，绝对，它是非常……而且它也非常清教徒，它非常……它非常焦虑地专注于试图让思想集中在不产生不纯洁的思想上，专注于专注于奎师那，进行念珠计数，虔诚的练习，而且它非常专制。对我来说，这就是念珠、虔诚的练习，而且它非常专制。对我来说，这就是整个古鲁传统的弊端，即它实际上，在核心上，是深刻专制的，而这种权威的主张是基于神圣启示，这在多种不同的原教旨主义宗教传统中都很常见。
It's what are they really saying? What's the point? Yeah. Yeah. And so you bring up something that maybe we can get into in a little bit, too, which is about whether or not the approach and the community has a process orientation. And how do you? How do you have something in religion that says or, you know, I think other communities that are about growth and changing that you need these rules now, but then you let them go. And it's not a hierarchy because it's not a cult. It's a giving up and having a deeper understanding.
以及一种字面化和受控的等级神圣启示。你没有直接的体验，你被告知那是什么。我认为这是你能够区分那种神话和宗教空间、哲学空间中坏东西和好东西的方法之一，之所以这么难，是因为如果你是一个僵化自我的人，需要成长，却紧抓着不健康的东西，比如酗酒，比如非常僵化的思维，比如，你知道，一个对你不起作用的哲学。然后有人说，嘿，放手，去感受，去存在，我会帮你带你去某个地方。那感觉太棒了。我怎么知道我被带入的是一个让我掌控并让我感受真实自我的过程？
How do you tell the difference between somebody who's done that and somebody who's gesturing at it? You know, because the language is the same. Yeah. Yeah. And one of the, you know, I know that you talk about cults a great deal too. So do we. So one of the really telling things for me about the American intersection with Eastern spirituality is that early on, one of the most popular and sort of most recognized Indian religious groups that became popular and got a lot of Western subscribers was the Hare Krishna movement, right? The Krishna consciousness movement. Would you like a flower? Say again?
还是有人要用“哦，不，放手，但要把这种控制权交给这个权威”来取代它？那感觉也相当不错，因为我不必面对不确定性和责任以及所有这些事情。你知道吗？是的。我认为确定性就是那个东西。当有人说，我不知道，你应该与不确定性共处。你应该感到焦虑。那么那是我试图寻找的。
Would you like a flower? Would you like a flower at the airport? Yeah. And so when you look at that, I think initially, and this kind of goes to our project too. Initially, when you look at that, you sort of say, well, look at these hippies. They look at these hippies. They've dropped out of society. They've had an acid trip, and they've decided that, you know, hidden spirituality is the truth. And they've got this funny haircut, and they've got the forehead streak, and they're wearing these clothes, and they're dancing around like happy clappers in the airport and trying to convert us but really that particular sect is incredibly authoritarian it it has way more in common with fundamentalist christianity than it does with the kind of
而当有人说，哦，你弄错了，那只是你的创伤。你需要听Rajneesh的。你知道，像这样，那是……那是不同的。是的。而且他们不仅会说，那只是你的创伤。他们会说，那只是你的自我。你的自我正在抵制向古鲁投降，因为你的自我害怕向伟大的奥秘投降。先向古鲁投降，
eastern mysticism that i think folks like you and i may have been drawn to at some point and nationalism just a different kind of nationalism absolutely absolutely it's it's very and it's also very puritanical it's very um it's very sort of um anxiously preoccupied with trying to focus the mind on on not having impure thoughts on on staying focused on on krishna doing the the counting of the beads the devotional practice and it's very authoritarian and this is this for me is the beads, the devotional practice, and it's very authoritarian. And this, for me, is the problem with the whole guru tradition, is that it is actually, at its core, profoundly authoritarian, and the claim of authority is based on divine revelation in a way that is common to multiple different fundamentalist religious traditions.
交出你的控制权，交出你的银行账户，你知道，做古鲁告诉你的任何事。哦，然后就像Rajneesh是一个很好的点，一个很好的例子。然后，如果你对古鲁戴着10万美元的手表并拥有一支劳斯莱斯车队这一事实感到任何不安，好吧，你难道没有一些需要解决的问题吗，因为你对物质如此矛盾？或者，你知道，实际上，古鲁是完全自由的。这是他们会提出的论点之一，Rajneesh是完全自由的，他可以拥有所有这些东西，但他保持开悟，但对你来说那会是一个问题，这就是为什么我们对此有评判。这是一个巨大的题外话，我不想偏离太远，但我只是好奇，从一个比我有更多那个时代经验的人那里，但对于Rajneesh，如果他
And a literal and controlled hierarchical divine revelation. You not having a direct experience you're being told what that is and i think that's one of the ways that um you being able to tell the difference between something bad and something good in that kind of mythology and religious space philosophical space is so hard is that if you're a rigid egoed kind of person who needs to grow and is holding onto something unhealthy, like alcoholism, like very rigid thinking, like, you know, a philosophy that's not working for you. And then somebody says, Hey, let go and just feel and be, and I'm going to help take you somewhere. And that feels so great. How do I know if what I'm being brought into is a process that puts me in control and lets me feel my authentic self?
完成了他的计划，嗯，没有被阻止，也没有任何有问题的内容被曝光，他们可能永远不会真正让他下台。如果他完成了他所说的他已经升天，基本上他要自杀，然后他的追随者阻止了他，然后被踢出去了。那是一个增长极其迅速的宗教。你认为如果他为自己殉道，那会成为一种继续扩张的文化力量吗？我不知道。
Or if somebody is going to just supplant, you know, that with, oh, no, let go, but then give over this control to this authority. And that feels pretty good, too, because I don't have to sit with uncertainty and responsibility and all this stuff. You know? Yeah. I think certainty is that thing. When someone says, I don't know, you're supposed to sit with the uncertainty. You're supposed to be anxious. Then that's me that I'm trying to find.
那是历史上的一个转折点，很有趣，因为那件事像野火一样蔓延，就在那个团体分裂时停止了。是的，很难说。我的意思是，Rajneesh的静修所（ashram）在浦那仍然存在，我去过那里，我花过……我在20多岁时在那里待过几个月。嗯，他们仍然赚很多钱，这实际上是那个组织的目的，他们仍然有很多来自世界各地的真诚追求者，在那里有很棒的体验，做他们的事情。我认为它比过去少了很多问题，少了很多虐待和剥削，
And when somebody says, oh, you're mistaking, that's just your trauma. You need to listen to Rajneesh. You know, like this, that's, that's different. Yeah. And not only would they say, that's just your trauma. They would say, that's just your ego. Your ego is resisting surrendering to the guru because your ego is terrified of surrendering to the great mystery. Surrender to the guru first,
实际上，可能几乎不再有虐待和剥削了。它只是另一个你可以去并做事情的静修中心，人们可能会相信一些古怪的事情，也许有一些负面的结果。但在Rajneesh活着并拥有真正权力和名声的时候，确实有人被打断了手臂。人们被，你知道，有很多非自愿的性行为发生。有很多古鲁告诉谁应该和谁睡觉。这真是离奇的事情。嗯，我表达犹豫的原因是关于它是否会继续增长，是因为它吸引的是一个非常特定的人群。你知道，谁是真的想退出社会并参与一个非常专注于自由爱的团体，那个团体非常专注于自由爱，非常专注于一种宣泄的、强烈的、只是表达一切、把一切都展现出来的东西。那是一种人，我认为，被那个所吸引，也许在更广泛的社会中并不常见。这是一个很好的观点。我没考虑到这一点。好吧，所以我的意思是，你关于内在实践的很多工作，我认为我们计划谈论的是这个想法，你知道，我要用我的语言，然后你用你的语言，你知道，因为我们可能来自两个不同的视角。但是，你知道，直觉对我来说是这种能够……或者如果你看像MBTI，直觉所描述的是能够看到你意识不到的非常复杂的模式的现象，你知道，所以有些人把它描述为这种直觉（gut feeling）。我们现在通过QEG和一些正在出现的新ERP以及大脑如何工作，知道这也是
turn over your control, turn over your bank account, you know, do whatever the guru tells you. Oh, and then it's like Rajneesh is a great point, a great example. Then, if you have any uneasiness about the fact that the guru wears a $100,000 watch and has a fleet of Rolls Royces, well, don't you have some issues that you need to work through that you're so conflicted about materiality? Or, you know, actually, the guru is totally free. This is one of the arguments they would make rajneesh is completely free he can have all of those things but he stays enlightened but for you that would be a problem that's why we're having judgment about it this is a huge aside i don't want to go too far off the course but i am just curious from someone who has more kind of experience with that time than i do but with the rajneesh's if he had
创伤储存的地方。所以受过创伤的人往往非常直觉，但直觉是无意识的。所以那种直觉可能并不是说这是一件对我来说重要的事情。我可能只是仍然害怕穿楔形毛衣的男人，需要处理这个问题。在治疗创伤之前你不知道。嗯，但当你，你知道，精神病时，你失去了看到什么是真实的能力。你知道，如果你通过，你知道，裸盖菇素或其他东西产生化学诱导的精神病，你部分地失去了那个。但能够看到那些模式对于成为一个创造者和拥有愿景非常重要，因为你真的需要几乎思考比你实际能思考的更多的东西，如果这有意义的话。而其中一个问题是
gone through with his plan um and hadn't been stopped and none of the problematic elements were exposed and they might not have ever been that really kind of dethroned him if he had gone through with his plan of saying that he ascended and basically he was going to kill himself and then and then his followers stopped him and then got kicked out. That was an incredibly fast-growing religion. Do you think that that would be like a cultural force that would have continued to expand if he had martyred himself to himself, basically? I don't know.
作为一个直觉型的人和一个内向者，或者有一个暂时把你放在那里的经历，你可以失去对这意味着什么的视角。你知道，有些人说，那是脑干。那是大脑中位于语言之下的部分。那是位于时间之下的。嗯，那是自我中更古老的部分，也许来自我们的进化遗产。其他人说，不，有一种灵性的东西是上帝，或者，你知道，有一些水晶共振。松果体正在变成天线，你可以听到宇宙。我不假装知道它是如何工作的。
That's a hinge point in history that is interesting because that thing was spreading like wildfire, and it stopped right when that group split up. Yeah, it's hard to say i mean the the rajneesha ashram still exists in puna i have been there i've spent uh i spent a couple months there in my early 20s um they still make a lot of money which was really the purpose of that organization and they still have a lot of sincere seekers who come from all over the world and and have amazing experiences there and do their thing. I think it's a lot less problematic than it used to be, a lot less abusive and exploitive,
我是治疗师，不是牧师。但确实有一种你可以拥有的体验。我记得当Dennis McKenna谈论Terence McKenna时，当他们第一次发现这些亚马逊蘑菇并将它们带回来时。他们基本上是在磕药，但他们看到了这些疯狂的东西。然后他们说，我们需要吃足够的蘑菇，把那里的东西带到现实世界中。然后人们就会相信我们，这听起来是一个如此疯狂的说法。但如果你来自一个1950年代白栅栏社区，在那里你从未接触过精神分析，从未接触过卡尔·荣格，从未接触过瑜伽，从未接触过任何这些东西，然后你吃了一些东西，你开始看到东西。有一种现实的丧失，也许这些东西只是真实的东西。你知道，
actually, like, probably hardly abusive and exploitive at all anymore. It's just another retreat center where you can go and do stuff and where people might believe some kooky things, and maybe there's some stuff that is negative as a result of that. But at the time of Rajneesh's life and real power and fame, there were people who were having their arms broken. People were being, you know, there was a lot of non-consensual sexual stuff going on. There was a lot of the guru telling who should sleep with who. And it's just bizarre things um i the reason i express hesitation about whether or not it would have continued to grow is that it was a very particular
我不知道。你能谈谈那个内在与外在世界，以及你是如何概念化这种关系的吗？我认为在你过去10分钟左右提到的几个不同话题之间有一条主线。你知道，那条主线的一个方面是改变的状态，对吧？所以当你冥想时，你会进入改变的状态。当你做瑜伽或做某种呼吸法时，你会进入改变的状态。我认为有一种改变的状态，通常很难追踪，当你与一个非常有魅力的领袖人物接触时，你会进入那种状态，他非常非常擅长像长时间眼神接触、冷读这样的事情，
demographic that that appealed to you know who was who was really looking to drop out of society and get involved with a group that was very focused on free love that was very focused on free love, that was very focused on a kind of cathartic, intense, just express everything, put everything out there. That's a type of person, I think, who's drawn to that, that maybe is not as common in the broader society. That's a good point. I didn't think about that. Well, so I mean, a lot of your work with internal practices, I think what we had planned on talking about is this idea that, you know, and I'm going to use my language and then you use your language, you know, because we're probably coming from two different perspectives. But, you know, intuition to me is this ability to be able to, or if you look at like an MBTI, what intuition is describing as this phenomenon of being able to see very complex patterns that you are not aware of consciously, you know, and so some people describe it as this gut feeling. We know now with QEG and some of the new ERPs that are coming out and about how brains work, that that's also where
你身上发生了什么，像捕捉你在那一刻如何反应这样的事情。有一种强大的移情，我认为是由那些拥有这些特定魅力能力的人唤起的，他们的生计是基于擅长这些。他们从一大群人那里获得自恋供应的能力实际上是基于那套技能。我认为这通常被低估了。所以那也是一种开放的状态。但当你谈到迷幻药时，我认为关于迷幻药在完全沉浸和强大方面有一些东西，就好像你整个大脑化学反应被如此彻底、彻底地改变了，以至于就像进入了一个不同的世界，就像进入了一个不同的世界，并且在那个不同世界中存在着深刻的神话诗意，
trauma is stored. So traumatized people tend to be very intuitive, but then the intuition is unconscious. And so that gut feeling may not be that this is an important thing for me to do. I may just still be afraid of men in wedge sweaters and need to deal with that. You don't know until you treat the trauma. Um, but when you're, you know, psychotic, you lose the ability to see what's real. You know, if you're having a chemical induced psychosis, psychotic like thing through, you know, psilocybin or something, you're partially losing that. But being able to see those patterns is really important to be a creative and to have a vision because you really need to almost think about more than you can actually think about, if that makes sense. And one of the problems with
深刻的神秘感，嗯，与我们可能熟悉的各种宗教语言和意象有各种重叠。我认为它打开了心灵中本来就产生这些东西的部分。但关于那个迷人之处在于，同时，与精神病、解释因果关系的方式以及可能产生幻觉或听到声音等方式有显著的重叠。现在，你如何解释它，我认为变得非常非常重要，你如何整合那种体验，你开始相信那种体验代表什么。对我来说，迷幻药是通往内在探索和工作的一个极其强大的门户，否则这些仍然很难触及。所以有一个能够，
being an intuitive person and an introvert or having an experience that temporarily puts you there is that you can lose perspective on what that means. You know, some people are like, that's the brainstem. That's the part of the brain that is beneath language. That's beneath time. Um, and that's the part of the self that is older, maybe from our evolutionary legacy. Other people say, no, there's a spiritual thing that's God, or, you know, there's some crystal resonance. The pineal gland is turning into an antenna and you can hear the universe. I don't pretend to know how that works.
心理上意识到并受过训练，并且能够保持非常扎实和中立，为正在发生的事情保持空间，并在体验的另一端，将其梳理出来并谈论它，并突出或将一些更心理、象征、隐喻的解释带到表面……这就像拥有一个非常强大的清醒梦，本质上。所以你可以把那个清醒梦与“哦，天哪，这实际上证明了所有这些”联系起来。
I'm a therapist, not a priest. But there is an experience you can have. And I'm remembering when Dennis McKenna was talking about Terrence McKenna when they first discovered these Amazonian mushrooms and they were bringing them back. They were tripping basically, but they saw this crazy stuff. And then they were like, we need to do enough mushrooms to bring something from there out into the real world. And then people will believe us, which seems like such a crazy thing to say. But if you're coming from a 1950s white picket fences community, where you're never exposed to psychoanalysis, never exposed to Carl Jung, never exposed to yoga, never exposed to any of these things, and then you eat something and you start seeing stuff. There is this loss of reality and that maybe this stuff is just a real thing. You know,
我是治疗师，不是牧师。但你确实可能会有某种体验。我记得丹尼斯·麦肯纳在谈论泰伦斯·麦肯纳时，提到他们最初发现这些亚马逊蘑菇并把它们带回来的时候。他们基本上是在磕药，但他们看到了这些疯狂的东西。然后他们说，我们需要服用足够多的蘑菇，把那里的东西带到现实世界中来。这样人们就会相信我们，这听起来真是太疯狂了。但如果你来自一个1950年代那种有着白色栅栏的社区，从未接触过精神分析，从未接触过卡尔·荣格，从未接触过瑜伽，从未接触过任何这些东西，然后你吃了一些东西，就开始看到各种景象。你会有一种现实感的丧失，觉得这些东西可能真的是真实存在的。你知道，
I don't know. Could you say something about that inner versus the outer world and how you conceptualize that relationship? I think there's a through line between a few different topics that you've brought up over the last 10 minutes or so. You know, one, one aspect of that through line is altered states, right? So there are altered states that you answer into when you meditate. There are altered states that you answer into when you do yoga or you do certain kinds of breath work. There is an altered state, I think, that often is hard for us to track that you enter into when you engage, when you are engaged by a charismatic leader figure who is really, really good at things like prolonged eye contact, at things like cold reading,
我不知道。你能谈谈内在世界与外在世界，以及你是如何概念化这种关系的吗？我觉得在你过去十分钟左右提到的几个不同话题之间有一条主线。你知道，这条主线的一个方面是改变的状态，对吧？当你冥想时，你会进入改变的状态。当你练习瑜伽或进行某种呼吸练习时，你会进入改变的状态。我认为还有一种改变的状态，我们往往难以察觉，那就是当你与一位极具魅力的领袖人物互动时，他们非常擅长长时间的眼神交流，擅长冷读，
what's going on with you, at things like picking up on how you respond in the moment. There's a powerful transference that I think is evoked by someone who has those particular charismatic abilities and that their bread and butter is based on being good at that. And their ability actually to get their narcissistic supply from a large group of people is based on that skill set. And I think often that's underestimated. So that's also a kind of open state. But when you get to psychedelics, I think there's something about how completely immersive and how powerful psychedelics are in terms of just like your whole brain chemistry is so radically, radically altered that it's like going into a different world it's like going into a different world and there are aspects of being in that different world that are profoundly mythopoetic
了解你的想法，擅长捕捉你当下的反应。我认为这种具有特殊魅力的人会引发一种强大的移情，而他们的看家本领就是擅长这些。他们从一大群人那里获取自恋供给的能力，正是基于这套技能。我认为这往往被低估了。所以这也是一种开放的状态。但当你谈到迷幻药时，我认为迷幻药的沉浸感和力量是如此强大，以至于你的整个大脑化学反应都发生了彻底的、根本性的改变，就像进入了一个不同的世界，就像进入了一个不同的世界，而身处那个不同世界中的某些方面具有深刻的神话诗意，
that are profoundly mystical um that have all sorts of overlap with with religious language and imagery that we may be familiar with i think it opens up the part of the psyche where that stuff comes from anyway but the the the fascinating thing about that is there's also at the same time, significant overlap with psychosis, with ways of interpreting causality and with ways of perhaps hallucinating or hearing voices or what have you. Now, how you then interpret that, I think becomes really, really important, how you integrate that experience, what you come to believe that experience represents. And for me, psychedelics are this incredibly powerful doorway into an aspect of inner exploration and work that otherwise remains very hard to access. And so having a guide who is able,
具有深刻的神秘色彩，与我们可能熟悉的宗教语言和意象有各种重叠。我认为它打开了心灵中本来就产生这些东西的部分，但最迷人的是，它同时也与精神病有显著的重叠，与解释因果关系的方式，以及可能产生幻觉或听到声音等方式有重叠。现在，你如何解读这些体验，我认为变得非常非常重要，你如何整合这种体验，你最终认为这种体验代表了什么。对我来说，迷幻药是一扇通往内在探索和工作的极其强大的门，否则这些领域很难触及。因此，拥有一位能够，
who is psychologically aware and trained and is able to stay really grounded and neutral and hold space for what's going on and on the other side of the experience, sort of work it through and talk about it and highlight or tease up to the surface some of the more psychological, symbolic, metaphorical interpretations of what's... It's like having a very powerful waking dream, essentially. And so you can either relate to that waking dream as, oh my God, this actually proves all of these
具备心理学意识和训练，能够保持脚踏实地、中立，并为正在发生的事情提供空间，在体验之后，能够梳理、讨论并突出或引出一些更具心理学、象征性、隐喻性的解读……这本质上就像做了一场非常强大的清醒梦。所以你可以把这场清醒梦理解为，天哪，这实际上证明了所有这些
supernatural beliefs that I want to believe for whatever reason. I think it's also very inflating. There's a very common experience that a lot of people in the psychedelic literature have written about, of a kind of psychedelic inflation, a sense of I have now had the revelation, I am now something like a prophet, I now know these things about life after death, or about the existence of a spirit world, or i've had some deity come and directly tell me what my mission in the world is all of that i think is profoundly fascinating if you see it as a waking dream and potentially profoundly derailing on multiple levels if you take it as being a literal experience of some ontological reality that you've discovered.
出于某种原因，我想要相信的超自然信仰。我认为这也会让人产生一种膨胀感。在迷幻药相关的文献中，很多人都写过一种非常普遍的体验，即某种“迷幻膨胀”，一种“我已经获得了启示，我现在就像先知一样，我现在知道了关于死后生命、精神世界存在的事实，或者有某种神灵直接告诉我我在世上的使命”的感觉。如果你把它看作一场清醒梦，那是非常迷人的；但如果你把它当作你所发现的某种本体论现实的字面体验，那在多个层面上都可能是极具破坏性的。
I think that's true. And I'm not a psychedelic guy, so I can't really speak a lot about those experiences. We do some psychedelic-like types of therapy. I mean, some people who have done a lot of psychedelics have told me when they do brain spotting or SLT or something like, this is the part of that that is helpful. I'm underneath everything. And so there's some overlap. It's not the same thing.
我认为确实如此。我不是那种沉迷迷幻药的人，所以我无法对这些体验发表太多看法。我们确实做一些类似迷幻药的疗法。我的意思是，一些使用过大量迷幻药的人告诉我，当他们进行脑点疗法（Brainspotting）或SLT等治疗时，他们觉得这正是其中有帮助的部分。我处于一切事物的底层。所以两者有一些重叠，但并不是同一回事。
And we do also work with an IV ketamine clinic, even though we don't do the ketamine. People going in that experience is also, I think, probably more helpful than what they think ketamine is doing with serotonin. I think a lot of times it's just treating the trauma. It's why the needle moves on depression but it seems like hold on are you saying that in your in your clinical practice you are working with with people who go and do the ketamine therapy and then come back and you we work with an iv ketamine provider and so the they were not able to administer that i want none of the red tape of that and i'm not set up to do it so they they go to a doctor who provides that, and then they're doing their preparation. It's kind of shamanistic.
我们确实也与一家静脉注射氯胺酮诊所合作，尽管我们自己不做氯胺酮治疗。人们去体验那个过程，我认为可能比他们认为氯胺酮在血清素方面所起的作用更有帮助。我认为很多时候它只是在治疗创伤。这就是为什么抑郁症的指标会发生变化，但似乎……等等，你是说在你的临床实践中，你与那些去进行氯胺酮治疗然后回来的人合作吗？是的，我们与一家静脉注射氯胺酮提供商合作，他们无法管理这些，我也不想要那些繁文缛节，我也没有条件去做，所以他们去找提供该服务的医生，然后他们进行准备工作。这有点像萨满教。
You don't lean too much into that language with insurance companies, but you're preparing them for what might be unlocked, and then they're feeling that. Yeah, and then you're doing integration work with them on the other side. Before and after. Yeah. You have to be careful with IV ketamine, just if anyone is listening, because a lot of those clinics don't tell you, but what they're doing is they're mixing the ketamine with a
你不会在保险公司面前过多地使用那种语言，但你是在为他们可能被解锁的东西做准备，然后他们会感受到这一点。是的，然后在另一端你与他们进行整合工作。前后都要做。是的。使用静脉注射氯胺酮必须小心，如果有人在听的话，因为很多诊所不会告诉你，但他们实际上是在把氯胺酮和一种
sedative. And if you request your medical records, you'll see that, but they don't tell you they're doing that. And if they're doing that, it's easier for them because it means that you may not have a be loud or have kind of traumatic re-experiencing. And research also says that you're probably worse off than you hadn't tried the ketamine when they do that. So it's not really an ethical thing, but that is something you want to look at if anyone's listening to this anywhere and is wanting to look at it, especially in America, you'll run into that. Interesting. Interesting. Yeah. So in terms of that, you know, thinking about inner world versus outer world, you know, how to hold intense waking dream type experiences, I think that that, for of continuum with regard to how much is this based on an actual practice and how much of this is just based on a set of metaphysical claims that
镇静剂混合使用。如果你索要你的医疗记录，你会看到这一点，但他们不会告诉你他们在这样做。如果他们这样做，对他们来说更容易，因为这意味着你可能不会大喊大叫或有某种创伤性的重现。研究也表明，当他们这样做时，你的情况可能比不尝试氯胺酮时更糟。所以这并不是一件合乎道德的事情，但如果有人在听这个节目并想了解它，特别是在美国，你会遇到这种情况。有趣。有趣。是的。所以就这一点而言，考虑到内心世界与外部世界，如何把握强烈的清醒梦式体验，我认为这在关于这在多大程度上基于实际实践，以及在多大程度上仅基于一套形而上学主张方面，存在一个连续体，
are offered a priori, right? The way in which the practice is held as a process of discovery again there's a continuum there versus on the other side of the continuum um a way of a way of um affirming a set of preconceived metaphysical or supernatural claims to me that's that's really a huge deciding factor as to whether or not I personally, and this is a normative claim, I see certain forms of spiritual practice and community as being healthy and others as being unhealthy in terms of, are they taking you more in the direction of integration, of self-awareness, of emotional intelligence, of relational fluency, of being able to live in the world
这些主张是先验提供的，对吧？实践被视为一种发现过程的方式，再次强调，这里存在一个连续体，而在连续体的另一端，是一种确认一套先入为主的形而上学或超自然主张的方式。对我来说，这确实是一个巨大的决定性因素，决定了我个人（这是一个规范性主张）是否认为某些形式的灵性实践和社区是健康的，而另一些是不健康的，即它们是否在引导你走向整合、自我意识、情商、关系流畅度，以及能够在世界上生活
in ways that are likely to lead to more happiness and more wholeness and more harmony, as well as an honest sort of engagement. Maybe you're having more harmony in your personal life, but you're engaging in a more activist way with the political world because that's valid too. Models of therapy do that too that are not great. Largely cognitive and behavioral models
的方式，这些方式很可能会带来更多的幸福、完整和和谐，以及一种诚实的参与。也许你在个人生活中拥有更多的和谐，但你以一种更积极的方式参与政治世界，因为这也是有效的。治疗模型中也有不好的做法。主要是认知和行为模型，
that got big after insurance to corporatize healthcare. But what they're doing is they're moving the anxiety from here to here. So like if you go into somebody who is, and there's great CBT therapists, but if there's somebody who's just doing manualized CBT by the book and you say, I'm drinking six beers, they'll just move the anxiety over here and say, we'll play six games of Monopoly now. And now, okay, you're cured. Now the slider's gone down, you know, because you're trying to turn everything empirical and you're only concerned with behavior that you can measure in a number um and and so i think saying like like an example of what you're talking about the nexium where they lowered all these ocd symptoms with these people
在保险业将医疗保健企业化之后变得流行起来。但他们所做的是把焦虑从这里转移到这里。所以，如果你去找一个……当然有很棒的CBT治疗师，但如果有人只是照本宣科地做手册化的CBT，而你说“我喝了六瓶啤酒”，他们只会把焦虑转移到这里，说“我们现在玩六局大富翁吧”。好了，现在你治愈了。现在滑块已经降下来了，你知道，因为你试图把一切都经验化，你只关心可以用数字衡量的行为。所以我认为，就像你谈到的奈克瑟姆（NEXIUM）的例子，他们降低了这些人所有的强迫症症状，
yeah because they had them having this rigid inner obsession that was damaging physiologically you know but their family saw it and said okay well you're not counting the cracks on the door as much so this must be good yeah yeah never mind the fact that you're being indoctrinated into a into a cultish group that ultimately is going to take away your agency and have you be hyper focused on your body weight and you know be grooming you for some sort of weird uh snm sex cult like well it seems like the groups that understand that the rules are there to get you to the experience and not the rules are there to worship the rule are the ones that work better you know as just philosophies it doesn't have to be a religion and that there is this kind of when you have an allegorical or a metaphorical language well like what you were
是的，因为他们让他们有了这种生理上具有破坏性的僵化内心强迫，你知道，但他们的家人看到了，说“好吧，你不再那么频繁地数门上的裂缝了，所以这一定是好事”。是的，是的，别管你正在被灌输进一个邪教组织的事实，这个组织最终会剥夺你的能动性，让你过度关注自己的体重，你知道，为你准备某种奇怪的SM性邪教。嗯，看起来那些明白规则是为了让你获得体验，而不是为了崇拜规则的群体，效果更好。你知道，作为哲学，它不必是宗教，而且当你有寓言或隐喻语言时，有一种……就像你
saying about how you go into this profound waking dream, basically with psychedelics, and that it's dangerous when you come back and you say, I have the information and no one else has the information. And I know all of these esoteric things that make me special. That is dangerous when you come back and say, this is an experience that lays dormant within all of us that can teach me these things. And I could share this with anybody, right? Like that, that is, that is a different framework than I've made. I've, I've had, now I have an evidence base of experience for all of these metaphysical beliefs that I want to be real, um, is not. And, but in the middle, you know, which is probably where a lot of therapists have a hard time and coaches and things have a hard time staying, is that Messiah complex of I know that the other people need this thing.
所说的关于你如何进入这种深刻的清醒梦，基本上是用迷幻药，当你回来并说“我有信息，而其他人没有信息”时，这是危险的。我知道所有这些让我变得特别的深奥事物。当你回来并说“这是一种潜伏在我们所有人内心深处的体验，可以教我这些东西，我可以与任何人分享”时，这是危险的，对吧？这与“我已经制造了……我现在有证据基础来支持所有这些我想要成真的形而上学信仰”是不同的框架。而且，在中间，你知道，这可能是很多治疗师和教练难以坚持的地方，那就是“弥赛亚情结”，即“我知道其他人需要这个东西”。
And I have to convince them because they don't know that they need it. But also, I have to have some perspective within that because I'm not the Messiah. I'm just a dude. And these problems go back to the Bronze Age. And they are bigger than being. Yeah, that's right. And I think that there's enough similarities with what it's like talking to someone who has had an intense manic episode that I think it's worth pausing and saying, okay, hold on. I know you're very excited about this and you've gotten these inspired revelations that you believe are the answer to all of
我必须说服他们，因为他们不知道他们需要它。但同时，我必须在其中保持某种视角，因为我不是弥赛亚。我只是个普通人。这些问题可以追溯到青铜时代。它们比人本身更大。是的，没错。而且我认为，与一个经历过强烈躁狂发作的人交谈的感觉有足够的相似之处，我认为值得停下来，说“好吧，等等。我知道你对这个非常兴奋，你得到了这些你认为是全人类问题答案的灵感启示，但让我们慢一点”。对我来说，这就是你进入“灵性逃避”对话的地方。所以在八十年代，像约翰·威尔伍德（John Wellwood）和杰克·康菲尔德（Jack Kornfield）这样的人，还有一些其他人，我可能没提到，但他们值得赞扬，他们观察到，特别是在寻求冥想的社区中，这些人（我提到的那些人往往是做过大量佛教冥想和研究，但也获得了临床心理学博士学位并担任治疗师的人）。他们真的在试图弄清楚，好吧，我们如何整合这些东西？我们如何整合当时他们所说的“东方心理学”和“西方心理学”？我们如何认识到，好吧，东方心理学或东方实践和哲学在这一点上确实有一些东西可以提供，
humanity's problems, but let's slow down a little. And for me, this is where you get into the conversation of spiritual bypass. So in the eighties, people like John Wellward and Jack Kornfield, and there were some others as well, who I'm probably not mentioning, who deserve credit, who sort of were observing that like within, especially communities of people that were seeking out meditation, these, you know, the people I'm mentioning tended to be people who had done a lot of Buddhist meditation and study, but who also had gotten PhDs in clinical psychology and were working as therapists. And they were really trying to figure out, okay, how do we integrate these things? How do we integrate what at the time they were talking about as like Eastern psychology and Western psychology? And how do we recognize that, okay, Eastern psychology or Eastern practices and philosophies have something to offer that at this point,
而我们的西方心理学可能缺乏，但也许这里有一条双向的道路，也许反之亦然，西方心理学的某些方面确实可以做到这一点。我认为非常迷人的一个地方，即存在奇怪重叠和经常脱节的地方，是围绕“自我”（ego）这个词，对吧？所以有一段时间，有一种趋势是将东方哲学灵性文本翻译成英语时使用弗洛伊德式的语言，特别是围绕“自我”这个词。所以，这种特定的弗洛伊德式联想或思考“自我”的方式，被引入了关于冥想的这些想法中，以一种我认为最终有点令人困惑的方式。你想知道一件更奇怪的事情吗？即使是……你知道，弗洛伊德的“自我”和“无意识”是潜意识，它是相当
our Western psychology maybe is lacking in, but then also maybe there's a two-way street there, maybe vice versa, there are aspects of Western psychology that, you know, can really do that. One of the places where, that I think is really fascinating, where there's a strange overlap and often disjunction there is around the word ego, right? So there's a whole, there was a trend for a long time of translating eastern philosophical spiritual texts into english using freudian language especially around the word ego so so so this the the particular freudian association with with or or way of thinking about ego sort of got it got imported into these ideas about meditation that in a way that i think ultimately was kind of confusing you want to know a weirder thing that that like even so you know freudian the ego and the unconscious is the subconscious is pretty
等级森严的，而荣格疗法不是，你知道，这就是分歧所在。弗洛伊德说“不，这不是潜意识，它不是次等的，它只是自我的另一部分。它是无意识。它只是非意识”。所以你有一些右翼阴谋论，有时会影响那些本应是了解“阴影”的人的荣格分析师，但很多人，特别是男性（我想检查一下自己，因为我倾向于那样），在他们生命结束时有点发疯。但很大程度上是因为他们正在回归这些弗洛伊德式的假设，即使他们讨厌弗洛伊德，他们也在谈论弗洛伊德，因为他们正在阅读西方的……他们正在阅读东方大师的翻译，并将其整合到他们的荣格实践中，
hierarchical whereas jungian therapy is not you know and that's the split as freud says no it's not the subconscious it's not less than it's just another part of self. It's the unconscious. It's just the not conscious. So you have kind of right-wing conspiracies that sometimes affect Jungian analysts who are supposed to be the people who know the shadow, but a lot of, especially men, which I want to check myself because I lean that way, just kind of go nuts at the end of their life. But a lot of it is that they're reverting to these freudian assumptions not even though they hate freud and they're going on about freud because they're reading western they're reading the translations of the eastern gurus and integrating it into their jungian practice
然后从……中提取一个弗洛伊德式的假设。我有这些人在70年代的录音，他们死于90年代，就像听着它一样。你可以看到它正在发生。就像我知道他们在读什么，他们说他们发现了这个东西。就像，天哪，我不知道。我认为这是一种如此奇怪的现象。但它确实……你可以看着它发生。这很迷人。而且这非常棘手。对于灵性逃避，我认为你进入了
and then then taking a freudian assumption out of. And I've got tapes going back to the 70s of these guys that died in the 90s, like listening to it. And you can see it happening. And it's like I know what they're reading and they're saying they found this thing. And it's like, oh, man, like, I don't know. I think that's such a strange phenomenon. But it really you can watch it happen. It's fascinating. And it is very tricky. With spiritual bypass, I think you get
这样一个地方，即“自我”成为了批判性思维的替代品，它成为了诚实面对创伤的替代品，它成为了任何所谓的“负面情绪”或判断的替代品，对吧？或者对大师的抵制，或者你知道，当你……对某些人来说，你进入了非常广阔的冥想状态，而这实际上变得杂乱无章且有点不稳定。“哦不，不，那只是你的自我坚持不放。你需要冥想更多。你需要更努力地推动。也许你需要服用更多的迷幻药”，而实际上这对那个人来说可能并不是那么好。灵性信仰体系意味着所有的痛苦都是幻觉。那只是自我。任何形式的批判性思维或判断或对科学证据的依赖，都只是
into this place where, okay, the ego becomes a stand in for critical thinking, it becomes a stand in for being honest about your trauma, it becomes a stand in for any kind of quote unquote, negative emotion, or judgment, right, or resistance of the guru, or that, you know, when you, when for some people you get into very expansive meditative states and that actually becomes disorganizing and a little bit destabilizing. Oh no, no, that's just your ego holding on. You need to meditate more. You need to push harder. Maybe you need to take more psychedelics and actually that probably may not be so great for that individual. the spiritual belief system meant that all suffering was an illusion. That was just the ego. That any kind of critical thinking or judgment or reliance on scientific evidence was just
一种较低层次的意识，害怕可以通过直觉实现的更高真理，对吧？通过神秘体验，通过进入你的内心。是的。进入你的内心，走出你的头脑。是的。那种知识主张的等级制度，因此我们找到了答案。答案是超越。答案是发现……没有自我，非二元意识是唯一存在的东西。你知道，尽管这些是
sort of a lower level of consciousness that was afraid of the higher truth that can be realized through intuition, right? Through mystical experience, through coming into your heart. Yeah. Coming into your heart and getting out of your head. Yes. That, that, that sort of hierarchy of, of knowledge claims that, that, and therefore that we have found the answer. The answer is transcendence. The answer is discovering the, the, that there is no self that, that non-dual consciousness is all that exists. You know, even though these are,
有趣的哲学和体验实践，值得探索，但当你开始听到那些强有力的主张时，它们本质上变成了否认我们人类体验中任何脆弱、无助、必须处理丑陋和我们希望世界有所不同的事情的工具。对我来说，这总是一个危险信号。这就是更心理学导向介入的地方。就像，“不，不，不，我们有创伤。我们有痛苦的情绪。我们的家庭有功能障碍。其中一些在很长一段时间内都会是悬而未决的。不会有什么解决方案能让你一直感觉良好”。那里有一个危险信号。生活很艰难。它本该是艰难的。如果你认为你能够控制所有的现实，并用你在内心做的事情让它变得容易，那你就是在被骗。这就是许多威权邪教领袖提供的承诺。然后发生的是，有一种内置的“诱饵和转换”，就像你说的，或者开始发生的倒置，即我向你承诺你可以一直快乐。你可以超越。
these are interesting philosophical and experiential practices to explore, the moment you start hearing those strong claims, which become essentially vehicles for denial about anything in our human experience that is vulnerable, in which we feel helpless, in which we have to deal with ugly and just things that we wish were
你可以与上帝接触。你可以实现宇宙最终的启蒙真理。当这种情况没有发生时，因为我的承诺是空洞的，与人类存在的现实不符，事实上，无法以一种真正尊严和富有同情心的方式容纳人类存在，当它没有发生时，那是你的错。这是因为你的自我阻碍了。这是因为你没有充分地向我投降。你没有做足够的服务工作，你没有在系统中变得足够像奴隶。也许我需要伤害你一点，
different about the world. To me, that was always a red flag. And that's where the more psychological orientation came in. It's like, no, no, no, we have trauma. We have painful emotions. We have dysfunction in our families. Some of this is going to be loose ended for a really long time. There isn't going to be some solution that just makes you feel good always. There's a red flag there. Life is hard. It is supposed to be hard. If you think that you're going to be able to control all of reality and make it easy with something you do in your heart, you're getting scammed. That's the kind of promise that a lot of authoritarian cult leaders offer. Then what happens is there's a built-in kind of bait and switch, like you said, or inversion that starts to happen where I have promised you that you can be happy all the time. You can transcend.
为了真正教导你，你让它伤害你是你的错。我告诉病人，当有人告诉你“自我”是所有痛苦的根源时，你知道，等到第六课，你会听到你是原因。这真的是你的错。脆弱是坏事。
You can be in touch with God. You can realize the ultimate enlightening truth of the universe. When that doesn't happen because my promises are empty and out of accord with the reality of human existence, in fact, unable to hold human existence in a really dignified and compassionate way, when it doesn't happen, it's your fault. And it's because of your ego getting in the way. And it's because you're not surrendering to me sufficiently. You're not doing enough service work and you're not becoming a slave enough within the system. And maybe I need to hurt you a little bit
你应该讨厌你的脆弱。你应该压抑它。你应该在外面讨厌它。这也是他们的错。这就是那种右翼转变，你知道，在灌输进行到一半时，即使审美是左派的，你也会达到那个点。你会和基思·拉尼尔（Keith Raniere）达到那个点，你会和……你知道，他们中的很多人，他们中的很多人。是的，没错，因为最终它是非常个人主义的，同时又是非常威权的。而它之所以同时是个人主义和威权的，
in order to really teach you that you letting that hurt you is your fault. I tell patients when somebody tells you that the ego is the source of all suffering, you know, wait till course number six and you're going to hear that you are the reason. It's really your fault. Vulnerability is bad.
是因为没有一种共同的、平等的发现真理的方式，也没有一种真正处理情绪和冲突以及纠正权力失衡的方式。为了让这种权力结构保持不变，所有这些都必须被压制。所以，如果它是个人主义的，那么这只是你的错。这不是……为了让这种权力结构保持不变，所以如果它是个人主义的，那么这只是你的错。这不是威权权力结构或错误的形而上学主张的错。现在，这在我和你坐在这里交谈方面变得相关，因为我不是……我不是什么心理学博士专家之类的，我只是……我也不是。
You should hate yours. You should repress that. And you should hate it out here. It's their fault too. And that's that right wing shift, you you know halfway through the indoctrination even if the aesthetic is lefty you're going to get to that point with a keith rainier you're going to get to that point with a um you know a lot of them a lot of them yeah that's right because ultimately it's very individualist while at the same time being very authoritarian. And the reason why it's individualist and authoritarian at the same time
我的一生中，我认为我在此时此刻坐在麦克风前具有某种合法性的地方，在于我们过去四年对“阴谋灵性”（conspirituality）的研究。所有那些与灵性逃避或威权主义或关于直觉告诉你的最终真理的能力的夸大主张有关的相同趋势、相同地标，我们开始看到，“哦，哇，这里有一个像克里斯蒂安·诺斯鲁普（Christiane Northrup）这样的人，她一直是一位深受喜爱的、某种程度上是女权主义的妇产科医生，她有……你知道，很多来自更自由的反主流文化人口统计学的人发现她是英雄，因为她说‘倾听你的身体’，我们……而且她准确地说，我们几个世纪以来一直处于父权制医疗体系之下，所以这里有一些照顾好自己的方法，这里有一些实践
is that there is no kind of communal egalitarian way of discovering what's true and way of actually working through emotions and conflicts and correcting power imbalances. All of that has to be suppressed in order for this power structure to remain. And so then if it's individualistic, then it's just your fault. It's not the fault of for this power structure to remain and so then if it's individualistic then it's just your fault it's not the fault of the of the authoritarian power structure or the faulty metaphysical claims now where this becomes relevant in terms of me sitting here talking to you because i'm not a i'm not a you know phd psychology expert or anything like that i've just been me neither
可能有助于你减压，可能有助于你更爱自己的身体，并更多地与你的直觉和女性智慧接触。就像，好吧，这一切听起来都不错，但最终在整个大流行期间，我们看到了已经存在的倾向，因为她已经是一个反疫苗者，而且她已经非常容易为了自己的利润动机和出于“整体论”的幌子而推广伪科学疗法。他们的灵性、预言性、直觉性的宇宙宏大计划哲学，与实际上是“匿名者Q”（QAnon）想法的想法结合在一起，并且有一个实际上是关于让特朗普重返办公室的议程，并将任何更进步的东西视为（你知道的）恋童癖撒旦阴谋集团的一部分。所以这很疯狂，这几乎是一系列不可避免的事情，所有这些人都在同一个等级森严的邪教中，他们是黑带。我的意思是，每个人……“匿名者Q”是一件大事，就像我遇到过一些人，
my whole life where i think i have some legitimacy in terms of being on the microphone right now is in terms of what we've studied over the last four years with conspirituality all of those same kinds of trends all of those same landmarks that have to do with spiritual bypass or with authoritarianism or with inflated claims about the the ability of the intuition to tell you the ultimate truth, we started to see, oh, wow, here's someone like Christiane Northrup, who's been a beloved, somewhat feminist OBGYN who has, you know, so many women from a more liberal counterculture kind of demographic have found to be heroic because she's saying listen to your bodies and we and who and she's accurately saying we've been under a patriarchal medical system for centuries and and so here are the ways to take better care of yourself and here are some practices
告诉我他们相信“匿名者Q”，我说“好吧，你相信什么？”他们告诉我他们相信的五件事，我认为是真的。我不认同相信“匿名者Q”，但我说“好吧，是的，那些事情确实发生了”，而且你是对的，这没有被谈论。好吧，让我们谈谈五件事中的一件，五件事中的一件，你知道，然后其中一些太离谱了，就像有人说“你知道，全世界周围有一堵五百万英尺高的冰墙，Q正试图让我们知道这一点，你知道，跟随金钱”，我说“我看不出钱去哪儿了”，但你知道，所有那些在水里的东西，就像你在这些邪教中看到的贯穿线，就像胶体银，以及，嗯，对灌肠的痴迷。我的意思是，
that might help you to de-stress and might help you to love your body more and be more in touch with your intuition and your feminine wisdom. Like, okay, like all of that sounds good, but ultimately more and more through the course of the pandemic, we saw the tendencies that were already there because she was already an anti-vaxxer and she was already very susceptible to promoting pseudoscience cures for her own profit motive and out of a claim of being holistic. their spiritual prophetic intuitive kind of cosmic grand scheme of things philosophy with ideas that actually were q anon ideas yeah and with with um an agenda that actually was about getting trump back into office and seeing anything that was more progressive as being part of the you know pedophile satanic cabal so it was wild it almost was a set of inevitabilities that all these people were on then one hierarchical cult where they were black belt i mean everyone q anon such a big thing like i've had people who
其中一些可以追溯到很久以前。我的意思是，人们在1800年代的福音派运动中就这么做了，你知道，有魅力的传教士和类似的人，会做一些推荐灌肠之类的事情。为什么所有这些没有……的群体，是否存在一种永恒的邪教审美？你知道，为什么前四个G不像最后一个那样具有威胁性？是的，好问题。为什么只有5G是问题？是的，看，我……我应该坦白，我对艺术、诗歌、神话和沉思实践，以及作为人类的整个方面非常非常着迷。我在日常生活中和我在世界上所做的工作中对此充满热情。与此同时，我对任何形式的超自然或超自然主张都持有深刻的怀疑态度。而且我实际上并不认为这些事情是矛盾的。奖励一种关于作为人类意味着什么的思考方式，这种方式在摆脱超自然和超自然信仰后，看到了更大的自由和更大的
tell me that they believe in q anon i'm like okay what do you believe and they tell me a list of five things that i believe that i think are true i don't identify as believing in q anon but i'm like well yeah those things did happen um and you're right it isn't talked about all right let's talk about one of the five things one of the five things you know and then there's some of it is just so out there like somebody's like you know there's a five million high ice wall all around the world that q's trying to let us know about you know follow the money and i'm like i don't see where the money is going here but you know all of those things that were kind of in the water, like the through lines that you see in these cults, like the colloidal silver and, um, the obsession with like enemas. I mean,
清晰度。那只是我。很多人不同意这一点。所以对我来说，我看着它说，好吧，任何依赖某种认知模糊的宗教或灵性组织，在那里你……你混淆了你可以对现实本质做出真理主张的基础，那么他们就会与许多不同的事物找到共同点，包括关于医学的伪科学主张，对吧？包括关于我们为什么生病以及我们如何保持健康的身体模型，这可能包括像“你要做灌肠，你要……”之类的事情。某种局外人的自力更生，粗犷的个人主义，你可以自己做。这总是会有吸引力。
some of these go back a ways. I mean, people were doing this with evangelical movements in the 1800s, you know, charismatic, um, preachers and things on that were, would do things like recommend enemas and things. Why does it that all of these groups who don't have is there a perennial you know cult aesthetic you know why were why were the first four g's not as threatening you know then then this last one yeah good question how come it's only 5g that is the problem yeah look i am, I should out myself as being really, really fascinated with art and poetry and mythology and contemplative practice, all that whole aspect of what it is to be human. I'm absolutely passionate about in my daily life and in the work I do in the world. And at the same time, I have a profoundly skeptical attitude towards any kind of paranormal or supernatural claim. And I actually don't find that those things are contradictory. rewards a way of thinking about what it is to be human that sees greater freedom and greater
然后，就我们的项目而言，有趣的是，当你发现没有好的科学证据表明胶体银实际上是所有病原体、所有病毒、所有细菌的灵丹妙药时。而且应该是某种能撕裂细胞壁的东西，比如当你吃它时杀死细菌并不是它唯一在做的事情。完全正确，完全正确。所以，当你真正审视关于伪科学疗法的说法是否属实的科学研究时，如果你被锁定并认同并已经将这些说法灵性化，那么很容易陷入一种阴谋论的心态，你会说，“好吧，当权者不想让你知道真相，因为他们正在从胶体银的竞争对手那里赚钱”，
clarity once free of the paranormal and supernatural beliefs. That's just me. A lot of people disagree with that. So for me, I look at it and I say, okay, there's any religious or or spiritual organization that relies on a certain kind of epistemic obfuscation, where you're you, you are muddying the waters about the basis on which you can make truth claims about the nature of reality, well, then they're going to find common cause with a lot of different things, including pseudoscientific claims about medicine, right? Including models of the body about why we get sick and how we can be healthy, which may include things like you're going to do enemas and you're going to, you're going to be like. Some kind of outsider self-reliance, rugged individualism that you can just do it yourself. And that's always going to be a appeal.
既然我们以那个为例。因此，你实际上无法相信证据所说的，因为它是被买通的。所以我们将继续服用我们的胶体银。非常感谢。最终我们就像艾米·卡尔森（Amy Carlson）一样，在年轻时就因为营养不良和银中毒而全身发蓝并死亡。
And then what's interesting about that in terms of our project is that when you find that there is no good scientific evidence for colloidal silver actually being the panacea that is the answer to all pathogens, all viruses, all bacteria. And should be something that rips cell walls apart, like killing the bacteria when you eat it is not the only thing that it's doing exactly exactly so so when you actually look at the science that has been done on whether or not the claims being made about the pseudoscience um remedy are true if you are locked into and identified with and have spiritualized those claims, then it's very easy to fall into a conspiratorial mindset where you say, well, the powers that be don't want you to know the truth because they're making money on the competitor to colloidal silver,
相信我，如果保险公司可以在支付癌症治疗和胶体银之间做出选择，他们会购买胶体银。如果有任何方法可以做一个研究来假装它有效，那是更便宜的选择。说得太好了。说得太好了。当你谈论将客观与神秘分开时，我的意思是，对我来说就是这样，我想，“神秘体验存在吗？你知道，有永恒的哲学吗？我能完全理解关于这些体验的一切以及为什么它们以某种方式存在吗？不，我不能”。但我所做的是利用它们进行反思，但我不会
seeing as we're using that as the example. And so therefore, you can't actually trust what the evidence says because it's all bought and paid for. And so we're going to keep taking our colloidal silver. Thank you very much. And we end up like Amy Carlson, completely blue and dead of malnutrition and silver poisoning at a young age.
假装我想要相信的东西（你知道，在那些状态或心灵的那部分中）实际上给了我对物质现实的任何控制权。我的意思是，当你说是“我的直觉告诉我这种药最好”时，那不是直觉的作用，你知道？所以对我来说，这实际上是直觉、情绪过程、躯体存在方式和自我发现路径，强加那种认为这告诉我们关于现实本质的某种超自然或超自然或超越性的东西的客观镜头，对我来说，这实际上是内心生活贬值的证据，是所有这些过程贬值的证据。
I believe me, if insurance companies could pick between paying for cancer treatments and colloidal silver, they would be buying colloidal silver. If there was any way to make a study to pretend that that worked, that is the cheaper option. Very well said. Very well said. When you're talking about separating the objective from the mystical, I mean, that's it for me is it's like, I think, does mystical experience exist? You know, like, are there perennial philosophies? Can I understand exactly everything about these experiences and why they are in a way? No, I can't. But what I, and what I do is use them to reflect, but I don't
这是一种虚假的确定性，而不是坐在不确定性中，而这应该是成熟、直觉和成长的重点。对我来说，一个人真正参与那种路径以及那种过程、体验、成熟、治愈、整合和个体化越多，这种情况发生得越多，作为人类的那一维度的巨大价值本身就越被欣赏。而且它不必被翻译成我实际上认为是一种相当肤浅和扁平的呈现方式。因为它是投射。
do is pretend that the things that I want to believe, you know, in those States or in that part of mind, it actually gives me any control over material reality. I mean, when you're saying my intuition is telling me that this medicine is best, that isn't the role of intuition, you know? So this for me is actually intuition, emotional process, somatic ways of being and paths of self-discovery, imposing that kind of objective lens that says this tells us something either paranormal or supernatural or transcendent about the nature of reality, to me, it's actually evidence of a devaluing of the inner life, a devaluing of all of those kinds of processes.
它是投射。它不是一种认同。是的。是的。所以与此相关的是这两种“赠品”，对吧？一个是这种想法，即你可以在某种程度上找到一种方法来控制许多作为人类我们实际上无法控制的事情。而且任何形式的心理工作都是在接受这一点。我无法控制那个。其他人无法控制那些特定的事情。面对一个一直并将永远是人类体验一部分的东西，我如何培养更大的同情心、更大的接受度、更大的谦逊？另一个是这种想法，即我可以……这与控制有关，但它更是一种“我可以显化”（manifest）的感觉，对吧？通过显化，通过用意图的力量变得足够专注，有时他们会引入扭曲的量子物理学来解释这一点，
It's a false certainty instead of a sitting in the uncertainty, which needs to be the point of maturity and intuition and growth. And to me, the more one actually engages in that kind of path and in those kinds of processes and experiences and maturation and healing and integration and individuation, the more that that is happening, the more the immense value in and of itself of that dimension of what it is to be human is appreciated. And it doesn't have to be translated into what I actually see as a quite superficial and flat way of presenting it. Because it's projection.
对吧？不知何故，我可以……我可以通过这种灵性觉醒按照我自己的形象创造世界，现在我正在显化我想要的一切。然后当然，如果我……如果那不起作用，那一定是，
It's projection. It's not an identification. Yeah. Yeah. And so related to that then is these two kind of giveaways, right? One is this idea that you can somehow find a way to have control over so many things that actually as human beings, we don't have control over. And really any kind of psychological work is coming to terms with that. I don't have control over that. Other people don't have control over those specific things. How do I cultivate greater compassion, greater acceptance, greater humility in the face of something that has just always been and always will be part of the human experience? The other is this idea that I can, and it's related to control, but it's even more the sense that I can manifest, right? And through manifestation, through getting focused enough with the power of intention, and sometimes they'll bring in mangled quantum physics to explain this,
一定是我该受责备，而不是因为我们生活在一个（你知道的）剥削性的资本主义体系中，或者我们没有足够的医疗保健，或者……或者你知道，这只是一个事实，你知道，我在这里，我有局限性。还有一件事与所有这些有关……我正在努力回想它是什么。它会想起来的。它会想起来的。当然。好吧，也许你所说的一个例子，也许这会让你想起，是塔罗牌，我做了很多关于原型的研究。
right? It's somehow I can, I can make the world in my own image through this kind of spiritual awakening where now I'm manifesting everything as I want it to be. And then of course, if I'm, if that's not working, it must be,
很多人去找塔罗牌占卜师。我不认为大多数人会这样做，但有些人去找塔罗牌占卜师，他们觉得塔罗牌占卜师会告诉他们未来会发生什么，你知道，或者做出什么选择来承担这种责任……你知道，当我这样做时，我有时会被出现的巧合所震惊，或者我的意思是，它有时确实感觉很神奇，特别是当你有一个直觉很强的人在帮助你时，但我看到的是我内心我不理解的一部分，我本可以避免的，或者自我两个部分之间的冲突。然后我更好地了解了自己，我知道该怎么做，这是我实际上可以拥有的真正控制权。如果我以为那是魔法，它只是在告诉我该去做什么，那就是放弃了我本可以拥有的控制权。
I must be to blame, not the fact that we live in, you know, an exploitive capitalist system or what have you, we don't have adequate health care or that or that you know that it's just a fact that you know here i am and i have limitations and there was one other thing that's connected to all of that um i'm trying to remember what it was it'll'll come to me. It'll come to me. Sure. Well, maybe an example of what you're saying, and maybe this will jog your memory to me, is tarot, which I do a lot of work with archetypes.
这就是讽刺之处。当我与某人进行原型工作时，我说，“你知道，你明白这个女王原型是这个吗？你知道，这是一种母性能量，但它不是主动获取权力。它是权力背后的权力”。
And a lot of people go to a tarot reader. I don't think most people do, but some people go to a tarot reader and they feel like the tarot reader is going to tell them what happens in the future you know or what choice to make to take this responsibility away um you know when i do that i i'm shocked sometimes by the coincidences that come out or i mean it does feel magical sometimes especially when you've got kind of an intuitive person who's helping you with it but what i see is a part of myself that i don't understand that i could have avoided or a conflict between two parts of self. And then I understand myself better and I know what to do, which is the real control that I actually can have. If I thought that was magic and it was just telling me what to go do, that's giving up the control that I have had there.
如果是阴影，它是操纵性的，但它也可以……无论如何。如果他们为了那件事向女王（上帝）祈祷，那就是这种外化，并没有帮助他们说“哦，我明白了，我在内心感受到了这一点。我感受到了它在哪里帮助我。我感受到了它在哪里没有帮助我。我看到了我在这里试图做什么”。你知道？这是一个完美的区别例子，朱莉。我认为这说得太好了，对吧？而且讽刺的是，你认为你可能已经欺骗了自己，认为你拥有更多的控制权，但你实际上把控制权放在了某个地方。我要说的另一件事与“空想性错视”（apophenia）有关。所以“空想性错视”是一种倾向，即看到并不真正存在的模式，并认为这些模式有
That's the irony. And when I do archetypal work with someone, what I'm saying, you know, do you understand that this queen archetype is this, you know, it's a, it's a maternal energy, but it's, it's not actively getting power. It's the power behind power.
意义，而实际上它们没有。再一次，这是一种扁平化的现象，即可以发现有意义的符号和隐喻。它们通常对我们有特定的意义。可能存在一种更广泛、更普遍的原型意义领域，但它们仍然必须通过个人生活和个人体验来参考，以便从那颗果实中真正挤出汁液。而对于“空想性错视”，它再次是……你知道，无论是数字命理学还是……你知道，你在“匿名者Q”中看到了很多这种情况，人们会拿特朗普总统的一条推文，他们会把所有不同的东西圈起来。“哦，他在这里用了数字13。看，他在引用Q”。
If it's shadow, it's manipulative, but it can also, whatever. If they're praying to the queen, God, for the thing, that's this externalization that is not helping them say, oh, I see, I feel this within me. I feel where it's helping me. I feel where it's not. I see what I'm trying to do here. You know? That's a perfect example of the distinction, Jolie. I think that's beautifully said, right? And it is the irony that you believe that you have kind of perhaps fooled yourself into thinking you have more control, but you're actually putting the control out there somewhere. The other thing I was going to say had to do with apophenia. So apophenia is this tendency to see patterns that are not really there and to think that those patterns have
“哦，他在这里说了这件事。那实际上是1846年宪法的这一方面被……的日期”，你知道，他们只是……“看这张我用Photoshop揭开的隐藏在……中的秘密图片”。完全正确。所以，你知道，它……它使得……当我二十多岁时，我是在灵性亚文化中长大的，你知道，我会有朋友，他们会去看一个新的公寓住，他们会把街道地址的数字命理学作为他们是否想租那个公寓的决定因素，
meaning when actually they don't. And again, it's this flat landing phenomenon where there are meaningful symbols and metaphors that can be discovered. Often they have meaning specific to us. There may be a sort of a wider, more universal sphere of archetypal meanings, but they still have to be referenced through the individual life and the individual experience in order for the juice really to be squeezed from whatever that fruit is. And with apophenia, it's again, this very, you know, whether it's numerological or it's, you know, you saw this a lot with QAnon, people would like take a tweet from President Trump and they would like draw circles around all the different things. Oh, he used the number 13 here. See, he's referencing Q.
你知道，或者他们会去合作社买杂货，他们会对每一样东西进行肌肉测试，他们会在店里待三个小时，因为他们必须对他们考虑购买的每一件东西进行肌肉测试，看看它是否适合他们的能量。我总是看着那种事情说，“你认为这给了你一条通往宇宙真正想让你下一步做什么的秘密途径，但这实际上看起来像是一种强迫性的、焦虑的（你知道的）外化尝试，试图找到某种会告诉你该做什么的东西，以便在不成熟的地方寻找确定性”。你知道，我曾经告诉过某人……
Oh, he said this thing here. That's actually the date that in 1846, this aspect of the Constitution was, you know, they just go. Look at this secret picture I unveiled with Photoshop hidden within the, uh, exactly. And so, so, you know, it, it makes, when I was in my twenties and I was, I was sort of growing up within spiritual subcultures, you know, I w I would have friends who would, they would go and look at a new, a new apartment to live in and they would factor into their decision whether or not they wanted to rent that apartment what the numerology it was of the
哦，他在这里说了这件事。这实际上是1846年的日期，宪法的这一方面被，你知道，他们就这样。看看我用Photoshop揭示的隐藏在里面的秘密图片，呃，没错。所以，你知道，这，这让我，当我二十多岁的时候，我在精神亚文化中成长，你知道，我会有朋友，他们会去看一套新的公寓，他们会把门牌号码的命理学作为他们是否想租那套公寓的考虑因素，
street address you know or they would they would go to the they would go to the co-op to buy their groceries and they would be doing muscle testing on every they would be in the store for three hours because they were having to muscle test every single thing that they were considering buying to see if it was going to be right for their energy. And I would always look at that sort of thing and say, you think this is giving you a secret pathway towards what the universe really wants you to do next but this actually just looks like an obsessive anxious you know attempt to externalize uh something that's going to tell you what to do to have certainty in a place where it's not really mature to look for it um you know i told somebody one time that was
你知道，或者他们会去合作社买杂货，他们会对每一样东西进行肌肉测试，他们会在店里待上三个小时，因为他们必须对考虑购买的每一件东西进行肌肉测试，看看它是否适合他们的能量。我总是看着那种事情说，你以为这给了你一条通往宇宙真正想让你下一步做什么的秘密途径，但这实际上看起来只是一种强迫性的、焦虑的，你知道，试图外化某种东西，告诉你该做什么，以便在一个不成熟的地方寻找确定性，你知道，我曾经告诉过某人，那是
doing like ghost hunting you you epiphany like you get a bunch of random data on a thermal projector static and then you look for a pattern in it and you know like i think so many of those things like cut us off from real human spiritual traditions that even as somebody who's a secular materialist we need you know you don't have you can believe in whatever spirituality you want wherever that comes from i don't care but i'm saying we need a ritual we need a myth we need a grounding and a lot of times these things are shortcuts that stop us from going there. Like I had this person who is listening to all this static and trying to hear the ghost's voice through the static. And I was like, you know, this ritual that you're doing, it doesn't look like it's feeding you. And if there is any capacity that you have, you know, whatever this means to hear the voice of the dead in your life, you're not going to hear it here. And you're listening in the wrong place. And, you know,
就像捉鬼一样，你会有种顿悟，比如你从热成像仪的静态画面中得到了一堆随机数据，然后你在其中寻找规律。我知道，我认为很多这类事情实际上切断了我们与真正的人类精神传统的联系。即使作为一个世俗唯物主义者，我们也需要——你不需要，你可以相信任何你想要的灵性，无论它来自哪里，我不在乎——但我想说的是，我们需要仪式，我们需要神话，我们需要一种根基。而很多时候，这些东西只是捷径，阻止了我们去深入探索。就像我遇到过一个人，他一直在听所有的静态噪音，试图通过噪音听到鬼魂的声音。我就对他说，你知道吗，你做的这个仪式，看起来并没有滋养你。如果说你真的有什么能力——无论这意味着什么——去听到生命中逝者的声音，你也不会在这里听到。你找错地方了。而且，你知道，
whether that's reflecting on what my granddad did and his good parts and his bad parts and his legacy, or feeling like I do have some ability to communicate or feel a presence or something, I don't care, but it's real. And it's, and's real and it's faith and intuition in a way that is more grounded, I think, than a lot of these kind of parlor tricks, essentially, that we make up to feel like we have control or we have certainty. Yeah, I think that's very, very well said. What I hear, and you've come back to this a few times in terms of uncertainty, in terms of being, you know, it's like, how do we hold a compassionate and honest space for the anxiety and the fear or the authoritarian or the cultish or the conspiratorial thing that's being sold to you, which is increasingly the case in our online and social media sphere, that we're serving things up that are very, very well crafted based on our past online behavior in terms of what our needs are, even needs that we're unconscious of, right?
无论是反思我祖父所做的一切，他的优点、缺点和留下的遗产，还是感觉我确实有某种能力去交流或感受到某种存在，我不在乎，但它是真实的。这是一种信仰和直觉，我认为比我们为了感到自己有控制权或确定性而编造的那些所谓的“客厅戏法”要扎实得多。是的，我觉得你说得非常好。我所听到的是——你已经多次回到这一点——关于不确定性，关于如何为焦虑、恐惧，或者那些向你兜售的威权主义、邪教式或阴谋论的东西，提供一个富有同情心且诚实的应对空间。在我们的网络和社交媒体领域，这种情况正日益普遍，它们根据我们过去的在线行为，精准地推送那些非常精心制作的内容，以满足我们的需求，甚至是那些我们自己都没意识到的需求，对吧？
To me, the self-awareness of exploring what are these deep needs, how do i get them met in ways that are actually beneficial and authentic and and and you're human in their sort of imperfection um that's that's huge and you know in in my daily life i continue to teach yoga classes i continue to hold ecstatic dance events you know i am in the world all the time valuing and offering to people the possibility of let's gather in community. Let's be present in our bodies. Let's explore what's going on on an inner level. are without any of the unrealistic promises or claims or attempts to control. And with an understanding that I'm just facilitating this as someone who works for you right now. I don't have some special enlightened insight into all of this.
对我来说，通过自我觉察去探索这些深层需求是什么，以及如何以真正有益、真实且带有某种不完美的人性方式去满足它们，这非常重要。在我的日常生活中，我继续教授瑜伽课程，继续举办狂喜舞蹈活动。我一直身处这个世界，重视并向人们提供一种可能性：让我们在社区中聚集。让我们活在自己的身体里。让我们探索内心深处正在发生什么。这一切都没有任何不切实际的承诺、主张或控制企图。并且我明白，我只是作为一个目前为你服务的人来促进这一切。我并没有什么关于这一切的特殊开悟见解。
This is just what I've done as a career. And so, yeah, I have some knowledge I can share, but I'm not claiming infallibility in any way. Yeah, in my own life, I find myself continuously seeking to make those distinctions and value how we explore and get those needs match in ways that are sustainable. So I'm right there with you. Well, this is a beautiful conversation. I really appreciate your time, but I want to be respectful of it also. And we would really like to promote your website and your podcast and any other
这只是我职业生涯中所做的事情。所以，是的，我有一些可以分享的知识，但我绝不声称自己绝对正确。是的，在我自己的生活中，我发现自己不断地寻求做出这些区分，并重视我们如何以可持续的方式去探索并满足这些需求。所以我完全赞同你的观点。这是一次非常美好的谈话。我非常感谢你抽出时间，但我也想尊重你的时间。我们非常希望能推广你的网站、播客以及任何其他
projects that you've got in the show notes. Is there anything that you want to tell people about? And I can include all of that links to get to all that stuff really quickly. Yeah, I think for the purposes of a conversation like this, conspirituality.net is the website. You can find Conspirituality Podcast on anywhere that you might listen to podcasts. And yeah, anyone who might be curious about what I'm talking about with regard to yoga and meditation and ecstatic dance, that kind of thing, you can find me at julianwalkeryoga.com. And yeah, that's pretty much it. You know, I've written over the years on different websites,
你在节目笔记中提到的项目。有什么你想告诉大家的吗？我可以很快把所有相关链接都放进去。好的，我想对于像这样的对话，conspirituality.net 是我们的网站。你可以在任何收听播客的地方找到《Conspirituality》播客。对于那些可能对我所谈论的关于瑜伽、冥想和狂喜舞蹈等内容感兴趣的人，你可以在 julianwalkeryoga.com 找到我。基本上就是这样。你知道，这些年来我在不同的网站上写过文章，
there's stuff out there in the world. I wrote an article called The Red Pill. Oh gosh, I'm forgetting the name of it because it's right at the beginning of the pandemic. I wrote an article for Medium about the red pilling of New Agers back in early 2020. That is probably my most read piece out on the web, so you can seek that out as well. Okay. We'll,
世界上还有很多其他内容。我写过一篇文章叫《红药丸》。天哪，我忘了它的名字了，因为它是在疫情刚开始时写的。我在 2020 年初为 Medium 写了一篇关于新时代运动者“红药丸化”的文章。那可能是我在网上阅读量最高的一篇文章，所以你也可以去搜一下。好的。我们
we will link to that. Yeah. One thing about this wild, wild country takes a strong, strong, strong, strong. strong it breaks a strong strong line but anything less anything less makes me feel like i'm wasting my time There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我们会附上链接。是的。关于这部《狂野之国》的一件事，它需要一种强烈、强烈、强烈、强烈的……它打破了一条强烈的底线，但任何低于这个标准的东西，都会让我觉得是在浪费时间。本集目前还没有评论。点击转录稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。